ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะ
เราก็คบกับครูฟ้าและครูหญิงมหา
ในวีดีโอระดับอะไรคะครูฟ้าในวีดีโอระดับ
อีกอินเนอร์ค่ะกะดิกินเลยเนาะ
พูดๆแล้วครูฟ้าคะวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันพุธค่ะค่ะ
วันพุธที่เท่าไหร่คะวันพุธที่ 9
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนมีนาคมค่ะปีพตอะไรคะปีพต
ต
2565 ปีพ.ศ
ต่อไปคะมีข้อ
2022 ค่ะค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะครูฟ้า
เมื่อวานนี้วัน
อังคารค่ะคิดทำไมส่วนวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวัน
ที่ 8 เดือนอะไรคะ
มีนาคมปีพตต
2565 ปีคศ 2  022 ห่างค่ะพรุ่งนี้วัน
อะไรคะพรุ่งนี้วันพฤหัสบดีค่ะวันที่เท่า
ไหร่คะวันที่ 10 ค่ะเดือน
มีนาคมปีพตต
2565 ปีคศ 2  0  2  2  5 ก็จะแล้วตอนนี้
เวลากี่โมงแล้วคะตอนนี้เวลา
12:00 นเที่ยงกี่นาทีคะครูฟ้า
26 นาทีค่ะค่ะเพียง 26 นาทีเป็นเวลากลาง
วันเป็นเวลากลางวันนะคะสายครูฟ้าโอเคไหม
สบายดี
ลูกค้าโอเคค่ะสบายดีแผงผู้แรง
แข็งแรงมากค่ะผู้หญิงสบายดีไหมคะ
ผู้หญิงไม่ค่อยสบายเลยค่ะครูฟ้าผู้หญิง
เป็นอะไร
ครูหญิงเนี่ย
อ้วนหัวค่ะครูฟ้า
ปวดหัวอันนี้หัวแล้วก็มี
แก้ปวดหัวค่ะไม่ค่อยสบาย
เขาทำไมผู้หญิงปวดหัวแล้วปวดหัวเนี่ยกิน
ยาหรือยังให้อ้ายครูหญิงเนี่ยตอนนี้อ่ะ
ตอนนี้เที่ยงใช่ไหมคะ
12:26 นาทีนานตอนเที่ยงตอนเที่ยงเนี่ย
ผู้หญิงกินยาแล้วน้องเป็นยาเม็ด
พาราเซตามอลที่เหมือนยาไหมคะ
หนักเข้าไปอีกผู้หญิงไงอะไรคะล่ะ
หนานชาแล้วครูฟ้า
ผู้หญิงให้ดูทั้งหลายอันนี้เป็นซองล่ะรู้
จักจังเลยน้องของโรงพยาบาลเห็นไหมคะโรง
พยาบาลก็มียา
พี่ยาว่า
จะออกไปโรงพยาบาลใหญ่ก็จะมียาใช่ไหมๆค่ะ
ผู้หญิงก็จะมียาเม็ดนะคะว่าผู้หญิงเนี่ย
โตแล้วสมัยโตแล้วแล้วกูหญิงเนี่ยตัวเอง
ถ้า
ถ้าเด็กๆตัวผู้ชายผู้หญิง
เด็กๆน้องก็จะหนึ่งถึงสิบขวบอันนี้เนี่ย
เด็กๆสมัยเด็กๆอาจจะ 12 แล้วกันและกัน
เนาะ 12 น็อคเด็กๆแต่ครูหญิงกับครูฟ้า
เนี่ยไม่ใช่เด็กๆโตแล้วก็ขุดเวลาแบบปวด
หัวไม่สบายกินยาเนี่ยนะคะก็จะเป็นยาเม็ด
ยาเม็ด
เป็นยาเม็ด
นิยาของผู้หญิงยาเมะโทรหาแม่วงกลมเป็นไหม
นี่นะยาเม็ดนะคะ
ชุดขาวไปหมดแล้วไว้ที่หัวแกละยาเม็ดนะคะ
ลา Weather เวลากินยินยาเนี่ยก็ต้องมีน้ำ
ไม่มีน้ำครูหญิงนะคะเวลากินยาเม็ดมากินยา
เม็ดแบบนี้เนี่ยน้ำเราก็อย่าแล้วก็กิน
โอเคหรอผู้หญิง
ถ้าแต่ครูฟ้าแล้วก็นักเรียนเนี่ยอาจจะมี
ยาแล้วก็
เราก็น้ำใช่ไหมคะ
มาก็กินยาก่อนนะคะมียาแล้วก็กินยาก่อน
แล้วค่อยมีน้ำมันก็ดินนานแต่ผู้หญิงเนี่ย
ดื่มน้ำก่อนแล้วก็กินยา
อย่า
แตะไม่เหมือนกันใช่ไหมอันนี้เป็นยาเม็ด
ใช้ยาเม็ดเนี่ยก็จะมีแบบนี้ที่เป็นวงกลม
แล้วเป็นกลมๆนะยาเม็ดแต่มันก็จะมียาเม็ด
ที่เป็นแบบนี้ใช่ไหมครูฟ้าอันนี้ก็เป็นยา
เม็ดอันนี้เนี่ยเราเรียกว่าแคบซูลนะอย่า
แคปซูลอยากจะสุดครูฟ้าทุกาชอบชอบคันไหนยา
เม็ดกลมๆหรือว่าแคปซูลสูตรน่ะว่าแคบซูล
มันอร่อยอร่อย
เฮ้ย
ยาเม็ดอ้ะนักเรียนยาเม็ดใช่ไหมคะวงกลมคะ
นักเรียนกิน
มันขม
หือ
ผมต้องมีน้ำชนะดื่มน้ำเร็วๆแต่ถ้าแคปซูล
อ่ะอ่ะ
อ้ากินเข้าไป
โอเค
ไม่คงครูฟ้าทะเลชอบแคปซูลใช่มั้ยแคปซูลก็
เป็นยาเม็ดนะคะเม็ดเป็นเม็ดเหมือนกันจะ
ได้อย่างนี้ก็มี
111  1  2  3  4  5  6  7 จะมันแผงนี้นะ
คะมี 7 เม็ด
เป็นยาเม็ดนะคะลิยาเม็ดนะกูฟ้าไหนคะวิ
สกปรกจังเลยอ่ะอายชื่ออะไรนะคะนักเรียน
อันนี้ก็เป็นยาเม็ด
ยาอะไรอย่าทำไมแปลกๆไม่ใช่ทำเป็นแคปซูล
แต่ว่าเป็นแคปซูลที่เป็นวงกลม
ถึงเนี่ย
เห็นแคปซูลใช้เป็นแคปซูลที่เป็นวงกลมบีก็
ได้นะ
วิริเวอร์บีแล้วมันเด้อ
เล่นออกไปกี่นะ
ผู้หญิง
นี่รถก็มีน้ำมีน้ำมีแต่นะคะไหนไม่รู้นัก
เรียนเห็นหรือเปล่าว่ามันมีน้ำอะอันมีนาม
ว่าผู้หญิงบีบเป็นก็มันพุ่งออกนะคะอันนี้
ก็เป็นยาเม็ดเหมือนกัน
สมัยแต่ก็มียาเม็ดอีกนะครูฟ้าอันนี้เราก็
เรียกว่ายานะไว้จะมีอินทรีย์ก็เป็นยาใน 5
เป็นยาวิตามินเยอะหรอกต่างอย่าวิตามินแต่
ว่านี่เป็นยาที่
ไทยแล้วเรียนนักเรียนดูนะคะอันนี้ยาอัน
นี้ยาเม็ดไวตามินซีแบบเม็ดที่วาดอันนี้
แหละเล็กๆนิยาย
ใหญ่ขนาดนั้นน่ะไม่รู้เหมือนกันโอ้โหเวลา
กินเนี่ย
ต้องดื่มน้ำนะมีน้ำแต่ต้องดื่มน้ำดื่มน้ำ
เยอะๆนะคะเป็นอันนี้ก็เป็นยาเม็ดเนาะ
เพราะว่ามันเป็นเม็ดนะคะแต่ถ้าเด็กๆใช่
ไหมเด็กๆเนี่ยอ่ะ
ไม่กินยาเม็ดถ้ามีเด็กแล้วก็บอกเด็กกินยา
ไม่กินไม่กินเด็กๆเนี่ยจะกินยาน้ำ
ยาน้ำเหรอกูอย่างนี้นะนี่ยาน้ำหรอ
อ๋อ
จะเป็น
เป็นน้ำนะยาน้ำจะได้ขวดใช่ไหมคะแล้วก็จะ
มีแก้วร้องเวลากินเนี่ยเวลากินก็คือเปิด
ขวดอ่ะ
ก็จะได้กินไม่ได้แล้วนะแล้วก็เท
เห็นไหมเป็นน้ำยาน้ำแล้วก็กินเวลากินอ้ะ
หืออร่อย
บอกไม่ชอบกินยาน้ำ
เอ้ย
ไม่โปรฟ้าชอบยาเม็ดไม่ชอบยาเม็ดไม่ชอบ
อย่า
ไม่แต่ยาน้ำอย่างอันนี้เนี่ยเวลาดมมันจะ
มีกลิ่นมิ้นนะคะแล้วก็เวลาดื่มเนี่ยหือ
อร่อย
โง่ผู้หญิงก็ดื่มได้นะคะจริงฟ้าก่อนฟ้า
เด็กๆอ่ะ
ครูพาเด็กๆอายุประมาณ
หนึ่งถึงสิบสองนั่นแหละเด็กๆอ่ะกูพากินยา
เม็ดไม่ได้เลยค่ะโหยังเม็ดนักเรียนยาเม็ด
ขอให้ดูพระเกียรติค่ะเม็ดให้
ย่านามากครูฟ้ากินยาน้ำได้ไหมถ้าอย่างว่า
ต้องกินยาน้ำเพราะเวลาไฟฟ้าไม่สบายไม่
สบาย
เหนื่อยฟ้าเป็นเด็กครูฟ้าต้องกินยาน้ำแบบ
นี้น้ำแล้วก็ไปโรงพยาบาลใช่แล้วพี่ปอพี่
ปอพี่ปอคุณหมอ
หมอจะมีแหละเพราะว่าโรงพยาบาลในโรงพยาบาล
ก็จะมีคุณหมอราคาะนีพโรงพยาบาลเนาะที่ฟ้า
บอก
มีคุณหมอ
คุณหมอก็จะมีอะไรนี้นะคะคุณหมอใช่ไหมใน
โรงพยาบาลคุณหมอบอกอะไรบอกว่าจะบอกว่ากู
ฟ้ากินยานะว่าก็บอกว่ากูฟ้ากินยาเม็ดไม่
ได้ยาเม็ดถ้ากินไม่ได้เวลากินแล้วมันแบบ
มันฉันง่วงไม่เบื่อเรียนฟังก็กินไม่ได้นะ
คะคุณหมอก็เลยโอเคเอายาน้ำให้คุณป๊าเก็บ
แบบเนี่ยก็ฟ้าเป็นเด็กเธอเป็นเด็กก็จะกิน
ยาน้ำมันเวลาตื่นอ่ะ
อร่อย
แต่ว่า
กูพาเนี่ยต้องกินยาเม็ดเหมือนกันนะคะมียา
เม็ด
ก็เลยเป็นอันนี้นะยาเม็ดของครูฟ้าหรอ
ใช่ค่ะคุณป้าต้องให้กูป่าวเนี่ย
กินยาที่กูหญิงดีดนี่เต็มห้องเลยค่ะ
เหมือนโรงพยาบาลนี่แม่คุณแม่เขาต้องมีแบบ
นี้และเอายาใส่แล้วก็บดบดบดคุณหมอเพราะ
ว่าบางครั้งเนี่ยมันจะมียาผงได้ไงกูฟ้า
ที่มันจะเป็นซองแบบเนี้ย
ของผู้หญิงคือยาผงเหรอฮะอันนี้เป็นผงนะคะ
เวลาที่นักเรียนฉี่สมัยฉีกซองฮี
ผงขึ้นจ่ายชายผมคืนไงแล้วก็ที่นี่ร้องเท
ดูใช่มั้ยมันจะเป็นผงเห็นไหมมันจะเป็นผง
ยาผมเพราะว่าบางคนเนี่ยเหมือนครูฟ้าไงกิน
ยาเม็ดจะมายาเม็ดไม่ได้อ้ะยาน้ำยาน้ำแบบ
นี้อ่ะเอาล่ะมิวนะคะก็กินไม่ได้
มันก็จะมียาที่เป็นผง
จะใส่น้ำสมัยมีน้ำมีน้ำเนี่ยแล้วก็ใส่น้ำ
ใส่น้ำใส่น้ำใส่น้ำอายอะ 555 ก็อาจจะ
สำเร็จใช่ค่ะยาผงอันนี้ยาที่กินได้นกยา
ที่กินได้เนี่ยจะมียาเม็ดนะคะ
ยาน้ำแล้วก็ยาผงมะลิกินได้แล้วยาที่กิน
ไม่ได้อ่ะอย่าที่กินไม่ได้เนี่ยมันจะมี
ยาทาสมัยยาทาๆอย่างครูหญิงเนี่ยก็มียานิ
อันนี้ก็เป็นยาทา
เจลนะใช่ค่ะเป็นเจวันนี้เป็นเจลนะคะผู้
หญิงและก็จะมีมีหลอดใช่ไหมคะมีหลอดยาแล้ว
ก็เขาก็จะมีไม้
หาสิ่งก็ต้องเปิดใช่ไหมคะแล้วก็ก็ใจมัน
ถ้าเล่นไม่ได้เนาะอันนี้มันเป็นเจลนะคะ
นักเรียนมาเป็นเอสโตรเจนอันนี้ก็เป็นยาทา
หรือพาจะแบบนี้ถ้าสมัยแบบนี้ครูฟ้าอ่ะ
เนี่ยโหไม่สบายที่ที่หลังสมัยที่หลังฝ้า
โอ้ย
ปวดหลังแล้วผู้หญิงก็
ซื้อยาทามายาถ้ามันจะเป็นหลอดแล้วเราก็
บีบ
ใช่ไหมคะนี่มันจะเป็นเหมือนครีมหน่อยครีม
แล้วก็กินได้เย็นนะแล้วก็ทากีฬาเรา
ทาทาอันนี้คือยาทากินไม่ได้
กินแล้วตาย
กินแล้วเนี่ย
อ่าอันนี้เป็นยาทาใช้มันจะมีแบบเป็นครีม
แต่ของผู้หญิงอันนี้เนี่ยเป็นยาทาเหมือน
กันนะคะแต่ว่าเป็นเจล
บิดนิดนึงก็ได้นี่เห็นไหมกูจะเป็นเจล
ผู้ชายๆค่ะมันจะเป็นเจลแล้วก็เจลเนี่ย
แล้วก็ทา
อันนี้ก็เป็นยาทาเหมือนกัน
อย่าทาอย่ามาจะเป็นหลอดนะคะ
คิดว่าจะผู้พักก็มียาทาและผู้ฟ้าใช่สิบ
หลังอย่าทาหรือว่าบางคนเนี่ยอ่าโอ้เพลง
ลืมนะคะถ้าไม่ได้ไม่ยาบางอย่างถ้าโอเคแต่
บางครั้งเนี่ยมันก็จะมียาที่เป็นแบบ
สเปรย์อ่ะนี่ใช่มั้ยแล้วก็ขีด
อย่าที่เป็นสเปรย์อันนี้ไม่ฉีดนะคะเพราะ
ว่ามัน
กี่จะมั้ยแล้วก็นวดเราเรียกว่านวดน่ะที
แล้วแบบ
งวดจ่ายสลายไปเป็นน้ำเห็นไหมเป็นน้ำเป็น
สเปรย์นะคะเอาไว้ฉีดหน่อยอ่า
สายนี้ก็เป็นยาที่กินไม่ได้เหมือนกัน
และมีอีกไหมผู้หญิงมีค่ะค่ะอันนี้มันจะมี
ยาเม็ดใช่มั้ยยาน้ำหรือว่ายาผงที่กินได้
แล้วก็มียาทาใช้ยาทาอันเนี้ยกินไม่ได้ที่
ประเทศไทยเนี่ยก็จะมียาดม
ยาดม
แต่นี่เป็นยาดมจริงๆนะแบบนักเรียนรู้สึก
แบบ
ร้อนแล้วแบบไม่โอเคใช่ไหมคะรู้สึกว่าป่ะ
ไม่โอเคนะเนี่ยก็ซื้อมามันจะเป็นยาแบบนี้
แล้วนักเลงก็เปิดนะคะเออแล้วก็
ดมไปเอายาเนี่ยที่จมูกก็
ดมอันนี้เป็นยาดมยาดมเนี่ยกินไม่ได้
ไม่ได้นะเรียนเอ๊ยเนื้อหาได้นะน้องมาได้
นะคะน่าฟังดียุงแบบ
แล้วก็ฟ้าฟันฝากเอายาดม
ยาดมเนี่ยจะไม่ใช่ไหมมันก็ทาทาทาได้อะ
หรือว่าครูหญิงบอกว่าผู้หญิงเนี่ยอ้ะปวด
หัวจะแวะจะเป็น migraine ปวดหัวแบบก่อ
สร้างไม่โอเคไม่ดมใช่ไหมปวดหัว
กินยาแล้ว
สมัยกินยาแล้วก็โอ้โหปวดหัวนะคะคุณก็เอา
ยาดมแล้วก็ถ่า
โอเคทาได้ยาดมเนี่ยทาได้กินไม่ได้นะคะดม
ได้พาได้ตายแต่ยาทายาแต่ถ้าการเนี้ยดมวิน
ทาทาได้สมัยทาทาทาแขนทาคอทาขมับนะทาได้
อ่าจงไม่ได้กินไม่ได้
ก็หมดแล้วใช่ไหมผู้หญิงมีอีกหนึ่งอย่าง
ลืมเป็นพญาที่กินได้อีกหนึ่งอย่างยาอะไร
คะคนไทยเรียกว่ายาอมน้องยาอมอย่างเวลาครู
ฟ้านะแบบ
พอไม่โอเค
ก็เองเองชาฉันมันฉี่ยากินเนี่ยเป็นเม็ด
หรือว่าเป็นน้ำ
อ่ะมันก็ยังไม่โอเค
มันไม่มียาทานตาที่นี่ขอ
ให้มีค่ะก็ต้องมียาอมสมัยยาอมก็คืออันนี้
ยังกินได้หรือเปล่าเนี่ยแกะยาอมมาแล้วก็
มียาข้างในและยาอมเนี่ยมันก็จะเป็นเม็ดนะ
คะเป็นเม็ดเราก็เอาใส่ป่ะเนี้ยบอก
ไม่
ไม่กลืนนะคะเอายาแล้วก็แล้วก็
แล้วก็ขวัญหวานๆมันก็ติดคอครูฟ้าเนี่ยพอ
กินยาอมก็จะ
ก็เปลี่ยนสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงให้นิยามโอห์ม
พอก็จะโอเคดีขึ้นนะคะทรายอันนี้ก็เป็นยา
ยาในประเทศไทยสมัยก็จะมี
นิยายอาร์รันคาร์คะครูฟ้ายาเม็ด
ยาเม็ดนะคะอ่ะมียาอะไรคะยาน้ำค่ะนี้ยา
อะไรคะยาผงค่ะ
อันนี้ยาอะไรคะยาทาอย่าทาอันนี้ยาอะไรคะ
อ้อมยาฉีดจะฉีดสเปรย์ทำมั้ยยาฉีดนะคะอ่ะ
อันนี้ยาอะไรคะยาดมหรอกยาดมมาก็สุดท้าย
นี้ยาอะไรคะยาอม 2 อันนี้ก็เป็นอย่าต่าง
แบบต่างๆนะคะส่วนวันนี้เราสองคนก็ต้องไป
ก่อนเนาะบทเวลาแล้วนะคะแล้วเจอกันใหม่
วิดีโอหน้าค่ะบ๊ายบายสวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ